the house impeachment inquiry it's
moving forward and more president
Trump's cabinet members are under
scrutiny today for what they knew and
when they knew it
CBS News confirms Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo was listening to the July
25th phone call between President Trump
and Ukraine's president that led to the
impeachment inquiry in the first place
we're also told that Attorney General
William Barr asked the president to call
Australia's prime minister asking for
help looking for the origins of the
Russia probe the Justice Department says
that was part of an ongoing
investigation House Democrats have sent
president Trump's personal attorney Rudy
Giuliani a subpoena for Ukraine related
documents CBS News spoke exclusively to
Vitaly Klitchko the former boxer who is
now the mayor of Kiev
Ukraine's capital Giuliani's firm
advised Klitschko in his 2008 bid for
mayor and he is mentioned in the house
subpoena
Klitschko says he never saw any
wrongdoing on Giuliani's part and claims
they never had a formal business
relationship and your bid for mayor
which we just friends I never have a
business sorry he never offered you
money you never offered to listen to so
you've never spoken about the finance or
election interference and the ingham era
never ever you never asked you for help
the intelligence community's Inspector
General issued a rare statement
defending the whistleblower against
Republicans who say the complaint had no
first-hand information the IG says the
whistleblower had quote direct knowledge
of certain alleged conduct